a few moments ago Buckingham Palace
announced the death of her majesty Queen
Elizabeth II the queen died peacefully
at Balmoral this afternoon the world is
mourning the loss of Queen Elizabeth II
the longest reigning monarch of Britain
just before the announcement at 10 30
a.m Pacific Time a rainbow could be seen
stretching across the skies above
Buckingham Palace where crowds gathered
as the news rippled across the globe and
the Royals rushed to the Queen's bedside
at Balmoral Castle in Scotland Queen
Elizabeth's son Charles just named his
majesty the king released a statement in
the wake of the devastating news quote
the death of my beloved mother her
majesty the queen is a moment of the
greatest sadness for me and all members
of my family we mourn profoundly the
passing of a cherished Sovereign and a
much-loved mother I know her loss will
be deeply felt your majesty
Mommy
and now Stars throughout Hollywood are
remembering the Beloved Queen I often
draw strengths from meeting ordinary
people doing extraordinary things
Jennifer Garner shared this stunning
photo and called her an elegant
incredible woman
Elton John who was knighted by the queen
in 1998 posted a lengthy note to Twitter
reading in part quote she was an
inspiring presence to be around Queen
Elizabeth has been a huge part of my
life from childhood to this day and I
will miss her dearly
[Music]
never did
former president Barack Obama and his
wife Michelle remember her majesty as a
Beacon of Hope and stability quote
Michelle and I were lucky enough to come
to know her majesty and she meant a
great deal to us she welcomed us to the
world stage with open arms we are awed
by her Legacy of tireless dignified
public service
another former President Bill Clinton
spoke out giving thanks for the Queen's
extraordinary life
quote we will always be grateful for the
kindness she showed us through the years
life of course consists of final
partings Ozzy Osbourne Mourns the loss
he says England without the queen is
devastating
George Takei also shares his condolences
quote there shall be none other like her
sharing a similar sentiment Sylvester
Stallone who paid tribute to the great
Queen with a photo of their first
meeting I'm very glad to be able to join
you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]